selamat kembali ke Quantum Computing in Practice saya Olivia Lan dan episod tiga hari ini akan fokus pada
eksperimen QAOA pada skala utiliti jika kamu dah ikut kami dari awal kamu dah lihat kami merangkumi
Perkakasan IBM Quantum kerangka kerja Qiskit patterns dan teknik pengurangan ralat terkini dan terhebat yang
digunakan oleh penyelidik dan pembangun untuk membesar-besarkan litar kuantum kami rasa ia sangat penting untuk memberi kamu semua
konteks ini dan menunjukkan arah yang kami tuju tapi kini tiada sebab untuk menunggu lebih lama untuk melihat semua maklumat ini dalam
tindakan kini beberapa perkara yang perlu diingat sebelum kita mulakan semuanya akan mengikuti kerangka kerja Qiskit
patterns jadi kita akan melalui langkah-langkah ini mengikut urutan nombor satu ialah memetakan masalah dua mengoptimumkan litar tiga
melaksanakan dengan Primitives dan empat pemproseson pasca atau menganalisis keputusan kita akan mulakan dengan contoh yang agak kecil
supaya kamu semua boleh memahami langkah-langkah ini dan tujuannya dengan baik kemudian kita akan bincangkan contoh yang sangat serupa tetapi jauh
lebih besar untuk menunjukkan kepada kamu bagaimana seseorang itu akan membesarkan masalah ke tahap 100 qubit saya akan memberi kamu semua
alat untuk membolehkan kamu maju selepas kuliah ini dan menjalankan masalah itu secara bebas terakhir ini tidak akan
menjadi panduan kod tidak kira seberapa keras kita cuba apabila kita membuat kemajuan kod menjadi lapuk dan usang jadi jika kamu
menonton video ini setahun selepas ia dilancarkan saya tidak mahu kamu terjebak dengan sintaks yang mungkin berubah sedikit dari masa ke masa sebaliknya ini akan menjadi
perbincangan terperinci tentang logik dan pernyataan masalah walau bagaimanapun terdapat tutorial notebook yang dipasangkan dengan
video ini yang dilampirkan dalam penerangan di bawah mengikuti kod atau merujuknya selepas kamu
menonton pelajaran ini dan menjalankannya sendiri akan memberi kamu pengalaman pembelajaran yang terbaik jadi sebagai peringatan ringkas bukan
semua masalah pengkomputeran sesuai untuk Pengkomputeran Kuantum masalah mudah dan pengiraan ringkas tidak perlu
memanfaatkan teknologi ini kerana komputer klasikal sudah sangat baik dalam menyelesaikannya sehingga 2024
tiga domain yang kita paling optimis untuk diterokai adalah ini mensimulasikan alam semulajadi memproses data dengan struktur yang kompleks
dan akhirnya pengoptimuman masalah pengoptimuman adalah antara masalah pengkomputeran yang paling sukar
untuk diselesaikan dengan cekap dalam masalah pengoptimuman kamu mencari nilai terbesar atau terkecil yang mungkin
untuk fungsi kos yang diberikan walau bagaimanapun untuk banyak masalah yang menarik mencari ekstremum ini menjadi lebih sukar secara eksponen
dengan saiz masalah itulah sebabnya ia menjadi sangat sukar untuk dikira sebagai contoh kamu boleh bayangkan betapa
sulitnya mengira laluan penerbangan optimum atau laluan penghantaran merentas negara dalam pelajaran ini kita akan
meneroka masalah pengoptimuman tertentu yang dipanggil Max Cut yang kita akan selesaikan dengan menggunakan
algoritma kuantum yang dipanggil quantum approximation optimization algorithm atau QAOA jadi apakah masalah max cut sebuah
masalah max cut adalah sejenis masalah pengoptimuman kombinatorial yang ditakrifkan pada graf di mana matlamatnya adalah untuk
mempartisi bucu-bucu graf kepada dua subset supaya bilangan tepi antara dua subset adalah
dimaksimumkan jadi contohnya dalam graf di sini setiap nod disambungkan seperti ini dan max cut ditunjukkan oleh garis bergelung ini
yang membahagikan nod kepada kumpulan ungu dan kumpulan kelabu cara untuk melakukan ini dengan melintasi bilangan
tepi terbesar yang mungkin adalah memotong melalui lima tepi untuk graf ini kerana graf ini sangat kecil
tidak susah untuk mencuba beberapa potongan yang mungkin di atas kertas atau bahkan dalam kepala kamu dan mengetahui bahawa lima adalah pilihan terbaik yang mungkin
tapi bayangkan jika bilangan nod berganda dan kemudian bertiga dengan cepat ini menjadi mustahil untuk dilakukan
dengan tangan dan selepas bilangan tertentu ia menjadi sangat rumit sehingga superkomputer pun bergelut untuk mengembalikan jawapan terbaik dengan boleh dipercayai ini kerana
bilangan maksimum potongan berskala secara eksponen dengan bilangan nod walaupun ini mungkin kelihatan agak abstrak
terdapat banyak masalah dunia sebenar yang boleh dibingkaikan sebagai masalah Max Cut seperti pengesanan penipuan dalam kewangan
pengelompokan graf reka bentuk rangkaian dan reka bentuk VLSI juga analisis media sosial
yang media sosial itu sangat mudah difahami katakanlah kamu ingin mencari sekumpulan individu yang mempunyai sebanyak mungkin
sambungan kepada individu lain pada platform media sosial untuk mengenal pasti pengguna berkuasa atau orang yang mempunyai
paling banyak pengaruh dalam kumpulan syarikat sebenarnya cuba melakukan ini agak kerap satu lagi perkara di sini max cut sering
merupakan subrutin masalah yang lebih besar jadi ia mungkin tidak mendefinisikan aplikasi sebenar tetapi digunakan di bawah selit ia adalah
jauh lebih biasa daripada yang kamu mungkin fikirkan secara naif kini tiba masanya untuk mulakan
langkah pertama adalah mencipta graf kamu boleh melakukan ini dengan mengimport pakej python yang dipanggil rustworks Tentukan berapa
ramai nod yang kamu kerjakan dengan menentukan nombor n kemudian tambahkan nod kamu pada graf G kamu juga akan perlu
melukis tepi kamu kita akan buat ini secara manual di sini dengan hanya menyenaraikannya dalam tatasusunan seperti ini di mana kamu tunjukkan nombor terakhir
yang menentukan berat tepi atau seberapa kuat dua nod yang ditentukan disambungkan di sini kita hanya akan
berpegang pada berat satu untuk semua tapi kamu mungkin seronok bermain-main dengan berat kemudian dan melihat bagaimana penyelesaian
berubah untuk mendapat gambaran tentang apa yang dimaksudkan dengan berat dalam konteks ini mari kembali kepada contoh media sosial kamu boleh fikirkan
berat ini sebagai seberapa berpengaruh seseorang kepada orang lain sambungan kamu kepada pasangan atau saudara mara kamu
contohnya mungkin akan diberi berat yang lebih tinggi daripada seseorang yang hanya kenalan sekarang lukis graf kamu
tutorial yang dilampirkan akan menunjukkan kepada kamu sintaks yang betul pertama sebelum mempertimbangkan cara untuk
memetakan masalah ini ke atas litar kuantum mari bina beberapa konteks tentang bagaimana masalah max cut menjadi masalah pengoptimuman
pada mulanya kita mulakan dengan pertama mempertimbangkan peminimuman fungsi f dari x di mana input x adalah
vektor n-dimensi yang komponennya berkaitan dengan setiap nod dalam graf kita akan merujuk fungsi ini dari sekarang
sebagai fungsi kos kita kemudian kita perlu mengehadkan setiap komponen ini kepada sama ada sifar atau
satu di sini bermakna di satu sisi potongan atau yang lain kita boleh tulis fungsi sebagai
pasangan nod xi dan xj yang memberitahu kita sama ada Tepi yang berkaitan berada dalam potongan jadi tambah kuantiti xi tambah xj
tolak xi kali xj mengenal pasti sama ada tepi berada dalam potongan jika kuantiti ini sama
dengan satu ini bermakna bahawa tepi berada dalam potongan jika tidak ia adalah sifar dan tepi tidak ada masalah mencari
bilangan maksimum tepi dalam potongan kemudiannya boleh diformulasikan sebagai memaksimumkan fungsi ini seterusnya kita sebenarnya akan
menambah tanda tolak global kepada fungsi ini menjadikan masalah baru bersamaan dengan mencari minimum fungsi ini
WEBVTT
sebaliknya dan jadi minimum f dari x dalam kes ini akan berlaku apabila bilangan tepi yang dilintasi oleh potongan adalah
maksimum kita pilih untuk membingkaikan masalah ini sebagai masalah peminimuman kerana ini membolehkan kita kemudian memetakannya ke atas masalah
peminimuman tenaga iaitu mencari keadaan dasar yang merupakan perkara yang komputer kuantum secara semulajadi sangat pandai lakukan
tapi ingat tiada apa yang berkaitan dengan Pengkomputeran Kuantum di sini lagi kita masih perlu merumuskan semula masalah ini kepada
sesuatu yang boleh difahami oleh komputer kuantum kita kini bersedia untuk mula menyelami dan memulakan kerja dan
langkah pertama adalah memetakan masalah ke atas litar kuantum mungkin tidak jelas bagaimana kita
akan pergi dari graf seperti yang baru kita lukis ke litar kuantum tapi mari kita lakukan perlahan ingat kita akan
cuba menyelesaikan masalah Max Cut ini menggunakan QAOA dalam algoritma QAOA kita pada akhirnya ingin mempunyai operator
Hamiltonian yang akan digunakan untuk mewakili fungsi kos masalah kita serta litar berparameter
ansatz atau keadaan percubaan yang akan kita gunakan untuk mewakili keadaan kuantum yang merupakan tekaan terpelajar atau calon
untuk penyelesaian kepada masalah kita boleh sampel dari keadaan calon ini dan kemudian menilainya
menggunakan fungsi kos dalam kes ini fungsi kosnya ialah f dari x tapi kita perlu menyatakannya dalam
cara yang terasa asli kepada komputer kuantum untuk ini kita akan mengambil kesempatan daripada siri transformasi matematik
untuk menyatakan f dari x sebagai fungsi tenaga Hamiltonian langkah pertama
proses ini adalah menyatakan masalah meminimumkan f dari x sebagai masalah pengoptimuman binari tidak berkekangan kuadratik
atau QUBO singkatannya QUBO adalah cara umum untuk merumuskan masalah pengoptimuman kombinatorial ini
di sini Q adalah matriks n-kali-n nombor nyata n berkaitan dengan bilangan
nod dalam graf kita lima untuk contoh ini dan X adalah vektor yang sama bagi pemboleh ubah binari dari
perumusan awal untuk menjalankan algoritma QAOA dengan berkesan kita perlu menyatakan masalah pengoptimuman kita dalam istilah
Hamiltonian yang merupakan operator matematik yang mewakili jumlah tenaga sistem khususnya kita mahu
mencipta Hamiltonian fungsi kos yang mempunyai sifat bahawa tenaga keadaan dasarnya atau nilai eigen minimum
berkaitan dengan minimum fungsi yang mengkodkan bilangan maksimum potongan pada graf g setelah kita
ada Hamiltonian ini semua yang perlu kita lakukan untuk menyelesaikan masalah pengoptimuman kita adalah menyediakan keadaan dasar Hamiltonian pada komputer kuantum kemudian
menyampel dari keadaan ini akan dengan kebarangkalian tinggi menghasilkan penyelesaian kepada peminimuman f dari X ternyata
kita bernasib baik kerana masalah QUBO sangat berkait rapat dengan dan sebenarnya setara secara pengkomputeran dengan
salah satu Hamiltonian yang paling terkenal dan meluas dalam fizik iaitu Hamiltonian Ising untuk menulis masalah QUBO
sebagai Hamiltonian Ising ini semua yang kita perlu lakukan sebenarnya ialah perubahan pemboleh ubah mudah untuk pergi dari
pemboleh ubah Boolean 0 dan 1 kepada pemboleh ubah spin negatif satu dan satu langkah ini adalah
mudah ia ditunjukkan dengan lebih terperinci dalam lampiran notebook yang dilampirkan untuk mereka yang berminat tapi pada akhirnya peminimuman ungkapan QUBO ini
adalah sama dengan peminimuman ungkapan ini menulis semula sekali lagi sedikit dan
kita ada Hamiltonian fungsi kos kita di mana minimum ungkapan mewakili keadaan dasar dan Z
menjadi operator Pauli-Z manakala b adalah pekali skalar nyata kini bahawa kita ada
Hamiltonian kita adalah mudah untuk menulis semula dalam istilah dua operator Pauli ZZ tempatan yang akan ditukar dengan mudah kepada
gate dua qubit dalam litar Kuantum kita sila rujuk notebook yang berkaitan untuk melihat bagaimana ini dilakukan tapi outputnya
diberikan oleh baris ini di sini perhatikan bahawa dalam contoh kita terdapat
enam objek atau rentetan Pauli kerana setiap satunya mewakili tepi dalam graf panjang rentetan sepadan dengan bilangan
nod jadi IIIZZ adalah lima nod dan rentetan akan terdiri daripada
identiti dalam semua kedudukan kecuali untuk indeks nod yang terlibat dalam tepi yang akan mempunyai terma Z dalam Qiskit
rentetan bit yang mewakili qubit diindeks ke belakang sebagai contoh tepi antara nod 0 dan 1 akan dikodkan sebagai
IIIZZ dengan Hamiltonian yang ditulis dalam istilah Pauli kita bersedia untuk membina
litar Kuantum kita litar Kuantum ini akan membantu kita menyampel penyelesaian yang baik dari komputer kuantum algoritma QAOA
terinspirasi dari teorem adiabatik yang menyatakan bahawa jika kita mulakan dalam keadaan dasar Hamiltonian bergantung masa
dan jika Hamiltonian berevolusi cukup perlahan dan diberi masa yang cukup keadaan akhir akan menjadi keadaan dasar
Hamiltonian akhir QAOA boleh difikirkan sebagai versi Trotter diskrit bagi algoritma
adiabatik kuantum di mana setiap langkah Trotter mewakili lapisan yang akan kita panggil P jadi
bukannya berevolusi dari satu keadaan ke yang lain dalam setiap lapisan P kita akan bertukar balik antara Hamiltonian fungsi kos kita
dan sesuatu yang dipanggil Hamiltonian mixer kita yang akan kita dengar lebih lanjut dalam sebentar lagi tapi perkara yang saya ingin tekankan
adalah bahawa QAOA mempunyai kelebihan menjadi lebih pantas daripada algoritma adiabatik kuantum tapi ia mengembalikan penyelesaian
yang hampiran dan bukannya optimum dalam had di mana bilangan lapisan pergi ke infiniti QAOA menumpu ke kes adiabatik
tapi sudah tentu ini sangat mahal secara pengkomputeran untuk mencipta litar Kuantum kita
kita akan menggunakan operator berselang-seli di sini yang diparameterkan oleh gamma dan beta yang
akan mewakili pendiskritan evolusi masa jadi sekali lagi tiga bahagian utama
litar QAOA adalah satu keadaan percubaan awal dalam kelabu yang merupakan keadaan dasar
mixer dari keadaan adiabatik yang dicipta dengan menerapkan gate Hadamard pada setiap qubit dua
evolusi fungsi kos yang sudah kita ada dalam ungu gelap dan tiga evolusi di bawah Hamiltonian mixer
yang belum kita bincangkan dalam ungu cerah kini Hamiltonian permulaan kita dipanggil
mixer kerana keadaan dasarnya adalah superposisi semua rentetan bit yang mungkin yang menarik seterusnya
menguatkuasakan campuran semua penyelesaian yang mungkin pada permulaan Hamiltonian mixer adalah jumlah mudah operasi Pauli-X
pada setiap nod graf Qiskit membolehkan kamu menggunakan operator mixer tersuai yang berbeza jika kamu mahu tapi
untuk kes ini kita hanya akan menggunakan yang standard jadi sekali lagi kamu boleh lihat bahawa dengan Qiskit banyak kerja adalah
ditanggalkan daripada kita menjadikan penciptaan Hamiltonian mixer dan Keadaan permulaan menjadi perkara remeh satu-satunya kerja yang perlu kita buat adalah
WEBVTT
mencari fungsi kos setiap iterasi operator-operator ini dipanggil lapisan lapisan-lapisan ini boleh dilihat sebagai
pendiskritan evolusi masa sistem seperti yang diterangkan sebelumnya corak berselang-seli datang dari
penguraian Trotter dan menghampiri fungsi eksponen bagi matriks yang tidak bertukar secara amnya lebih banyak lapisan atau
langkah yang kita sertakan semakin dekat kita kepada evolusi masa berterusan jadi secara teori semakin tepat hasilnya akan
menjadi tapi untuk contoh ini kita akan mulakan dengan hanya menyampel dengan dua lapisan ingat kedua-dua Hamiltonian fungsi kos dan
mixer adalah berparameter kita masih perlu mencari nilai optimum untuk gamma dan
beta kini saya sedar itu adalah banyak maklumat dan jika kamu melihat jenis matematik ini buat kali pertama ia boleh menjadi rumit syukurlah satu daripada perkara yang menyenangkan
tentang Qiskit adalah bahawa banyak daripada apa yang baru kita lalui boleh dilakukan secara automatik tanpa beban besar dari pengguna adalah baik untuk memahami apa yang
berlaku di bawah selit terutamanya apabila kita membesar-besarkan kepada eksperimen yang lebih besar tapi kamu tidak perlu melakukan semua kerja ini
dengan tangan setiap kali kita kini telah memetakan masalah kita ke atas litar Kuantum ia adalah sedikit kerja
tapi jangan risau ia menjadi lebih mudah dan lebih intuitif semakin kamu melakukannya kini kita bersedia untuk beralih ke langkah dua
mengoptimumkan litar kita untuk Perkakasan jadi walaupun litar yang baru kita cipta kelihatan agak mudah dan
berguna untuk membina pemahaman intuitif ingat cip kuantum tidak faham apa blok yang diabstrakkan ini
kita perlu mengubahnya kepada siri gate satu dan dua qubit yang asli kepada perkakasan dan apabila saya
katakan asli saya maksudkan ia akan dirangka semula kepada apa yang boleh dilaksanakan terus pada qubit litar sedemikian dikatakan
ditulis dalam seni bina set arahan backend yang mungkin kamu lihat disingkat sebagai litar ISA
modul transpiler SDK Qiskit menawarkan siri laluan transpilasi yang boleh
melakukan pelbagai transformasi litar kita ingin memastikan litar kita dioptimumkan untuk
tujuan kita ingat dari pelajaran sebelumnya bahawa proses transpilasi melibatkan beberapa langkah pemetaan
qubit dalam litar atau pemboleh ubah keputusan kepada qubit fizikal pada peranti pengekodan arahan dalam
litar kuantum kepada arahan asli perkakasan yang sebenarnya difahami oleh backend penghalaan mana-mana
qubit dalam litar yang berinteraksi secara langsung kepada qubit fizikal yang bersebelahan antara satu
sama lain dan seperti selalu lebih banyak butiran tentang ini boleh didapati di laman dokumentasi
kini datang langkah yang menarik di mana kita akan memilih backend mana yang akan dijalankan litar kita kita sebenarnya perlu melakukan ini
sebelum langkah transpilasi kerana transpiler mengoptimumkan secara berbeza untuk pemproses yang berbeza ini adalah satu lagi sebab mengapa penting bahawa Qiskit boleh mengautomasikan
banyak peringkat ini kamu tidak mahu terpaksa mengoptimumkan litar kamu dengan tangan
yang boleh dilakukan tapi kadang-kadang ia sukar dan memakan masa hanya untuk sedar bahawa kamu sebenarnya ingin menjalankan
litar kamu pada pemproses yang berbeza dengan sifat yang berbeza dan kemudian kamu perlu melakukan semua kerja itu lagi hantar
backend pilihan kamu melalui fungsi transpiler dan jangan lupa untuk tentukan tahap pengoptimuman kamu
kali ini saya telah memilih tahap pengoptimuman tiga yang merupakan tahap pengoptimuman tertinggi dan paling menyeluruh
dan itu sahaja untuk langkah dua litar saya ditranspilasi secara automatik dan saya lukis di sini supaya
kamu boleh melihat bagaimana ia diterjemahkan kepada gate satu dan dua qubit kini tiba masanya untuk langkah tiga
menjalankan litar dengan Primitives Qiskit setakat ini kita telah mentranspilasi litar dengan membiarkan parameter gamma dan
beta tapi kita tidak boleh menjalankan litar sebenarnya tanpa menentukan nilai parameter-parameter ini dalam aliran kerja QAOA
parameter QAOA optimum ditemui dalam gelungan pengoptimuman berulang di mana kita menjalankan siri penilaian litar
dan menggunakan Pengoptimum klasikal untuk mencari parameter beta dan gamma yang optimum walau bagaimanapun kita perlu mulakan
dari suatu tempat jadi saya telah melaksanakan beberapa teka-teki awal untuk Gamma 1 gamma 2 dan beta 1 beta 2 bagi Pi per 2 dan Pi
masing-masing saya juga ingin kamu perhatikan bahawa kita akan menggunakan pengoptimum untuk mencari penyelesaian yang lebih baik untuk gamma dan beta
dan kerana saya hanya mengira dua lapisan buat masa ini itulah sahaja yang saya perlukan tapi jika kamu membuat litar QAOA yang lebih tepat
kamu akan menyertakan lebih banyak lapisan dan dengan itu memerlukan gamma dan beta yang dioptimumkan untuk setiap lapisan berurutan
kini mari kita ambil masa sebentar di sini untuk berhenti dan ingat pilihan kita untuk Primitives kita ada estimator dan
sampler yang mana yang kamu fikir kita akan gunakan untuk jenis kerja ini nah tidak kira yang mana satu yang kamu
teka kamu sebenarnya betul kita akan menggunakan kedua-dua estimator dan sampler untuk pengoptimuman awal
kita akan memerlukan estimator tapi kita akan menggunakan sampler kemudian untuk membaca penyelesaian akhir
kini kita hampir bersedia untuk menjalankan algoritma kita saya janji tapi dengan cepat adalah penting untuk ambil perhatian bahawa kamu boleh
menghantar kerja kamu dengan pelbagai cara berbeza yang dipanggil mod pelaksanaan pertama kita ada mod kerja iaitu satu
permintaan primitif estimator atau sampler yang dibuat tanpa pengurus konteks litar dan input dibungkus sebagai blok
bersatu primitif (PUBs) dan dihantar sebagai tugas pelaksanaan pada komputer
kuantum mod batch adalah pengurus multi-kerja untuk menjalankan eksperimen dengan cekap yang terdiri daripada sekumpulan
kerja bebas gunakan mod batch untuk menghantar berbilang kerja primitif serentak mod sesi iaitu tetingkap berdedikasi
untuk menjalankan beban kerja berbilang-kerja ini membolehkan pengguna premium bereksperimen dengan algoritma variasi dengan cara yang lebih
dapat diramal dan bahkan menjalankan berbilang eksperimen serentak memanfaatkan keselarian
timbunan gunakan sesi untuk aliran kerja berulang dan eksperimen yang memerlukan akses berdedikasi untuk eksperimen QAOA
sesi akan menjadi pilihan yang baik untuk diteruskan jika kamu mempunyai akses kepadanya kerana kamu perlu mencuba berbilang litar untuk nilai beta yang berbeza
dan gamma okay kini mari kembali kepada masalah pengoptimuman kita kita sudah
menentukan Hamiltonian fungsi kos HC dan aliran kerja penuh adalah ini algoritma QAOA
bermula dengan memulakan qubit dalam Keadaan superposisi dan kemudian menerapkan ansatz dengan lapisan P ia
memulakan parameter gamma dan beta dan kemudian menjalankan litar menggunakan primitif estimator setelah kita mengira
nilai jangkaan kita kemudiannya akan menggunakan Pengoptimum SciPy yang dipanggil COBYLA COBYLA
mengoptimumkan fungsi kos secara klasikal di luar QPU setelah nilai gamma dan beta itu dikemas kini kita
ulangi kita akan melakukan ini sehingga nilai keseluruhan fungsi kos telah menumpu dan mencapai nilai terendah
WEBVTT
kemudian kita akan memilih nilai gamma dan beta yang berkaitan dengan nilai kos rendah ini dan menjalankan litar satu kali terakhir
kini menggunakan sampler ini adalah hasil saya menjalankan Pengoptimum COBYLA dengan teka-teki awal saya di sini kamu boleh melihat
bahawa nilai fungsi kos sepanjang iterasi yang dilakukan bermula sedikit tidak menentu dan ia naik turun tapi
kemudian ia menetap pada nilai yang rendah kita akan menggunakan nilai gamma dan beta terakhir ini yang berkaitan dengan nilai fungsi kos minimum
untuk menjalankan litar satu kali terakhir dan menyampel rentetan bit yang akan memberikan kita max
cut kini menggunakan nilai yang dioptimumkan untuk gamma dan beta kita akan menjalankan litar satu kali terakhir untuk mencari
rentetan bit terbaik yang mungkin menggunakan sampler saya senaraikan nilai khusus yang saya gunakan di sini tapi ingat apabila kamu cuba
tangan kamu pada ini atau bahkan hanya menjalankan semula notebook tutorial yang sama nilai-nilai ini mungkin berubah sedikit kini kita akan menjalankan
litar yang dioptimumkan dengan nilai-nilai ini dan mencari penyelesaian calon kita kepada masalah Max Cut kita jika kamu menggunakan
sesi itu tidak lagi perlu kerana kita hanya menjalankan satu kerja terakhir kini kita akhirnya akan melihat
peringkat pemprososan pasca dan mencari penyelesaian akhir kita pertama mari plot semua
kemungkinan kombinasi nod yang telah kita tukarkan kepada rentetan bit sebagai histogram kamu boleh lihat terus bahawa
apabila saya menjalankannya saya jumpa empat penyelesaian dan mengetengahkan yang dalam ungu yang lebih mungkin daripada penyelesaian lain
penyelesaian rentetan bit yang tertinggi dan dengan itu paling mungkin ialah 01010 sila ambil perhatian bahawa urutan qubit
adalah terbalik dalam plot melihat penyelesaian yang paling mungkin kita perhatikan bahawa nod 0 dan tiga dikumpulkan bersama
dan begitu juga untuk nod 1 2 dan empat kita akhirnya boleh memplot rentetan bit yang paling mungkin
semula sebagai graf dan ingat rentetan bit hanya berkaitan dengan nombor nod dan jika mereka disertakan
ditandai dengan satu atau tidak disertakan ditandai dengan sifar dalam kumpulan kita apabila kita lukis potongan kini kita boleh lihat dengan mata kita
garis hampiran untuk potongan terbaik yang hanya mewakili kumpulan ideal semua lima nod yang saya lukis di sini satu
perkara yang ingin saya luangkan masa untuk bincangkan di sini walau bagaimanapun ialah hakikat bahawa penyelesaian yang betul tidak unik
kerana simetri graf ini terdapat berbilang penyelesaian yang betul bukannya mempunyai nod 0 dan tiga berada
dalam potongan kita boleh mempunyai nod 2 dan empat yang disertakan dan kamu boleh lihat semua yang perlu saya lakukan adalah memutar potongan saya untuk
menyertakan titik-titik baru ini penyelesaian lima ini Tetap Sama
mari lihat semula histogram dan empat penyelesaian yang paling mungkin sebentar dua penyelesaian terakhir adalah
yang baru kita plotkan dan mereka sama-sama betul tapi itu belum semuanya kita juga boleh membalikkan pewarnaan untuk semua
penyelesaian yang betul dan kali ini kita hanya fikir nod sebagai berada di dalam berbanding di luar potongan pada
slaid sebelumnya kita mengenal pasti dua penyelesaian betul yang unik tapi sebenarnya ada dua lagi penyelesaian satu yang berkaitan dengan
kebalikan setiap satunya lihat di sini di mana saya melukis dua penyelesaian yang tinggal semua yang saya lakukan adalah membalikkan
warna kini satu-satunya masalah ialah algoritma sebenarnya tidak menjumpai atau mengenal pasti penyelesaian terakhir keempat ini sebagai
salah satu daripada empat jawapan yang paling mungkin ia adalah yang kelima penyelesaian keempat yang dikenal pasti oleh algoritma adalah
sebenarnya tidak betul dan jika kamu melukirnya kamu akan melihat bahawa penyelesaian itu hanya mempunyai empat potongan dan kerana yang lain
mempunyai lima dan empat jelas lebih kecil daripada lima ini jelas salah perkara di sini
ialah ini adalah algoritma hampiran ia tidak sempurna dan ia tidak betul 100% sepanjang masa kamu memang perlu
menggunakan pengetahuan dan pemahaman kamu sendiri untuk semak akal penyelesaian ia berbaloi untuk ketengahkan bahawa
ralat ini boleh timbul dari beberapa tempat ia boleh menjadi sifat hampiran algoritma itu sendiri dan bilangan kecil
lapisan yang saya pilih untuk gunakan ia boleh menjadi ralat pensampelan terhingga dan ini boleh dikurangkan jika saya meningkatkan
bilangan tembakan dalam eksperimen saya atau ia boleh menjadi ralat pembacaan kerana penyelesaian nyata keempat hanya berbeza sebanyak satu
bit sebab saya menunjukkan semua kemungkinan ini ialah inilah yang diperlukan untuk benar-benar menjadi seorang
pengamal Pengkomputeran Kuantum kamu perlu memahami prestasi perkakasan dan bagaimana ini boleh menyumbang
kepada jenis ralat tertentu dan cara untuk membetulkannya walau bagaimanapun jangan lupa bahawa terdapat
32 kemungkinan penyelesaian rentetan bit dan bahawa empat penyelesaian nyata termasuk dalam lima calon terbaik
terbaik dan saya hanya menggunakan dua lapisan untuk mendapati ini secara amnya jika saya ingin meningkatkan peluang untuk mendapati
max cut terbaik setiap kali saya akan meningkatkan kedalaman lapisan terdapat beberapa kehalusan untuk ini tapi itu untuk episod kemudian
kini saya akan biarkan kamu mencuba sendiri tapi kali ini kamu akan menggunakan 100
qubit jadi jika kita mulakan dengan melukis graf 100 qubit kita kamu boleh lihat bahawa ia tidak lagi mudah atau bahkan mungkin
untuk meneka di mana max cut akan berlaku terdapat terlalu banyak kemungkinan untuk dapat memilihnya dengan tangan tapi
menyelesaikan masalah ini menggunakan QAOA masih boleh dilakukan sepenuhnya dan kamu boleh mengikuti aliran kerja yang sama persis yang kita gunakan untuk 5
qubit saya akan menghantar kamu pergi sendiri dan menugaskan kamu untuk mencuba melakukan eksperimen ini tapi sebelum saya berbuat demikian mari
ringkaskan ingat bahawa enam langkah mana-mana kerja QAOA adalah seperti berikut satu menentukan
Hamiltonian kos supaya keadaan dasarnya mengkodkan penyelesaian kepada masalah pengoptimuman dua menentukan
Hamiltonian mixer tiga membina operator yang berkaitan dengan Hamiltonian yang dipotenkan
empat membina litar ia akan terdiri daripada keadaan dasar awal mixer dan lapisan berulang berselang-seli
fungsi kos dan evolusi di bawah Hamiltonian mixer lima sediakan keadaan awal dan
gunakan teknik Pengkomputeran Klasikal untuk mengoptimumkan parameter enam jalankan litar ukur rentetan bit output
mencari penyelesaian yang paling mungkin kini beberapa perkara yang perlu diambil perhatian di sini saya
menggunakan tahap pengoptimuman tiga untuk contoh 5 qubit saya tapi mungkin itu tidak perlu dan jawapan yang betul boleh
masih dikembalikan sebahagian besar masa pada tahap pengoptimuman yang lebih rendah kerana kedalaman litar agak rendah untuk kes 5
qubit tapi untuk 100 qubit dan kedalaman litar yang besar kamu hampir pasti akan memerlukan tahap tertinggi
pengoptimuman untuk mencari jawapan yang betul juga ingat bahawa salah satu bahagian yang paling mencabar aliran kerja utiliti biasa
adalah peringkat pemetaan dan mencari graf yang berkaitan baik dengan topologi heavy hex IBM jika kamu
melakukan kerja ini dari awal itu tidak syak lagi di mana kamu akan meluangkan banyak masa buat masa ini bahagian ini telah
WEBVTT
dilakukan untuk kamu kerana itu bukan tujuan utama latihan ini tapi ingat bahawa ia adalah sesuatu yang kita akan
perlukan berlatih dan menjalankan kerja berskala besar tidak selalu mudah kita akan menyelami ini
lebih lanjut dalam episod 4 litar akhir kamu akan jelas kelihatan jauh lebih tidak kemas daripada litar yang dijalankan pada 5 qubit
tapi di sisi lain saya rasa melihat litar ini dan melihat betapa banyak gate yang dimilikinya dan mengetahui bahawa kamu
mempunyai keupayaan untuk benar-benar menjalankan ini pada pemproses Kuantum sebenar adalah agak
menakjubkan dan ini adalah penyelesaian akhir saya kamu boleh lihat bahawa algoritma pasti mampu mengumpulkan
nod-nod ini kepada dua kumpulan didakwa mengenal pasti max cut terbaik yang membahagikan mereka dari dua set
kepada garis max cut itu sendiri adalah mudah di mana sahaja warna bertukar sepanjang garis yang menghubungkan nod menandakan
di mana garis max cut harus dilukis apabila saya menjalankannya nilai max cut yang saya berjaya capai adalah
84 jadi cuba sendiri dan beritahu saya jika kamu mendapat sesuatu yang serupa dalam komen cuba tiga lapisan mungkin empat cuba
menukar berat antara nod dan lihat bagaimana itu mengubah hasilnya terdapat banyak eksperimen yang menarik
yang boleh kita jalankan dengan QAOA kini ingat tidak dijamin bahawa saya baru sahaja menemui penyelesaian terbaik yang mungkin
kita tahu ia adalah penyelesaian yang baik tapi untuk keseronokan saya cabang kamu untuk cuba mengalahkan saya lihat sama ada kamu boleh mendapatkan sesuatu
yang lebih baik daripada 84 kesimpulannya QAOA adalah algoritma yang sangat dinamik
dan terdapat banyak heuristik dan banyak lagi yang masih perlu diterokai ia memberi banyak ruang untuk mempelajari perkara baru
tentang bidang pengoptimuman secara amnya terdapat banyak kerja baru-baru ini dalam ruang pengoptimuman seperti yang
dibuktikan oleh semua kertas arkib yang baru-baru ini diterbitkan dalam talian tentang QAOA atau pengoptimuman dan apa yang
sangat menarik ialah akhirnya bukan semua kertas-kertas ini adalah kertas teori ahli teori telah bekerja dan mengkaji
QAOA selama bertahun-tahun tapi kini eksperimentalis pula terlibat kerana kita akhirnya mempunyai perkakasan
seperti pemproses IBM yang mampu menjalankan banyak eksperimen ini kita beranjak dari ruang imaginatif
ke dunia sebenar dan itu sangat mengujakan ya masih ada banyak kerja yang perlu dilakukan dan masih ada
banyak ralat yang perlu kita cari tahu cara untuk ditangani tapi kita membuat kemajuan pesat dan kamu yang menonton
video ini jika kamu telah sampai sejauh ini mampu untuk menjalankan eksperimen-eksperimen ini sendiri sila pergi cuba menjalankan
eksperimen 100 qubit kamu sendiri dan beritahu kami bagaimana jalannya ikut tutorial dan kamu akan berada dalam tangan yang baik dan jika kamu
mempunyai sebarang soalan atau tersekat jangan risau kita semua rasa begitu atau mempunyai soalan yang sama apabila kita mula
belajar ini buat yang terbaik beritahu kami soalan apa yang kamu hadapi dan kita akan jumpa lagi pada kali berikutnya
[Muzik]